ah
[Music]
this is an over Rob hi everyone I'm
Walter Bonet the act and this is top
five not in the best mood now so today
we're counting down the worst of this
Mighty Morphin sequel series
right now over on my personal channel I
have a review up for money Morphin alien
Rangers which was the bridge between
this and the first three seasons of the
original show check that out for more
thoughts on the lead-up to view Power
Rangers vo was the fourth season of the
series and started the status quo of all
new powers and costumes every year to
match up with the newest Super Sentai
season airing in Japan while there was a
shake-up in a few areas
vo was a logical continuation of the
show and featured a lot of what we had
come to expect from Power Rangers at
that point that meant some really strong
episodes some of the strongest in the
Zordon era and some really bad ones
while these episodes never quite reach
the lowest point of money more fans
worst episodes they still aren't easy to
get through these are the top five worst
episodes of Power Rangers vo number five
bulk fiction book fiction isn't a
terrible episode it feels like it blends
in with a lot of the less than average
efforts this season but with four clear
frontrunners I needed something for
number five and this just barely fits
the bill both become smitten with the
police chief's daughter and tries a
little too hard to impress her before
attempting to ask her to a charity
donation dance Volks bumbling has an
adverse effect on lieutenant Stone's job
simultaneously the Rangers contend with
King mondo and Prince brockett's latest
monster Google Heiner
I love Vulcan skull okay but this is a
little creepy
glad to be on the street Tyrion man
[Music]
both tries very bulk like things to make
the Chiefs daughter Connie fall for him
but it eventually ends up costing
lieutenant stone his position in the
police department which sets up their
roles as detectives for the rest of the
season stolen what is that your man yes
sir I'm afraid of what as you know I
will not tolerate any recognising in the
race there's pressure with my daughter
yeah nothing like this ever happens
again
a true thespian the chief is towards the
end of the episode at this dance all the
Rangers come dressed as their favorite
decade Billy is of course dressed in
future gar because he's just too cool
Tommy and rocky are dressed in disco
suits which creates an interesting
moment
[Music]
the ending freeze-frame also looks like
David Yost has just had enough plant
yourself right there as we dive into
number four number four a few bad seeds
ever want to see rocky turn into a plant
and act like a complete fool for no
reason you're in luck
somehow rocky accidentally creates a
metal eating plant that grows at an
alarming rate
when Balkan schools steal a piece of it
to grow their own plant King mondo turns
both vegetations into monsters called
pollinator and Adrien pollinator later
sprays rocky with a substance that
slowly turns him into a plant himself
the Rangers must find a way to destroy
these latest threats and save rocky
before it's too late how could you not
love an episode that opens with this
inviting face isn't that great this
episode is just really really weird
we learned that lieutenant stone loves
the smell of that's really quite
fascinating sir
[Music]
oh the monsters here are spoofs of
Stallone and Schwarzenegger why'd you
bring it back here huh because your
cousin here is inept ah okay so your
point is one of them is named Adrian I
think it was just so we can get this the
strangest thing about this episode is
how rocky is slowly being transformed
into a plant weird enough but why do
they have him acting like this hey nice
leave nicely yeah you've got nice leaves
it branches on bad either
[Music]
they beat the pollinator by shooting him
with pure oxygen from their zeal
blasters okay makes about as much sense
with anything else I guess this was a
peculiar episode what am i crying about
it number three for crying out loud if
there's one thing that's always fun to
CN Power Rangers it's dangerous crying
babies when Tommy and Kat are partnered
up for a school assignment they have to
pretend to be married to make the
assignment more realistic Kat brings in
a family friend's baby for the couple to
care for King mondo decides to create a
monster to amplify the babies crying now
whenever little Joey cries it feels like
an earthquake
the machine empire then kidnaps the kid
and it's up to the Rangers to get him
back before he destroys all of Angel
Grove while the last episode was just
plain weird
this one is both annoying and boring
go home on top of the constant amplified
baby cries we find out that lieutenant
stone doesn't know how to squeeze
ketchup out of a bottle
I thought Balkan school were supposed to
be the dumb ones there's a bit of
foreshadowing here on Tommy and cats
relationship that develops later in the
season that's about the only noteworthy
thing this episode has to offer
boo hoo the clown is also a wonderful
antagonist for the Rangers as long as we
can keep the baby from crying maybe fine
yeah can't keep the baby from crying
very long that's true
crying did I yell about babies what's
the little guy so we can give it a good
one Tommy you better get over here Tommy
and cats teacher asked them to babysit
his twins at the end and I don't think
I've ever seen a human talk like this
I trust you discovered taking care of a
family isn't is easier to load well I'm
glad to hear you say that my wife and I
need a babysitter for Saturday dining he
has for the twin
number two the puppet blaster scariest
episode of the whole series right here
by sidekick while a children's show
called captain Pete is performing for
kids at the youth center King mondo
sends down cogs to corrupt Pete's
robotic friend puppet man and is
successful in turning him into a monster
now working for the Machine Empire
puppet man casts a spell on the kids in
the audience as they begin causing havoc
the Rangers must try to break the spell
and stop puppet man before he takes over
the minds of children all over the world
kids and Power Rangers have always been
hit or miss all right like 99% miss this
is no exception
you'll have to get through my lieutenant
Stone's nephew might be the worst let me
go let me go tell him uncle you were
mean to me
[Music]
oh there's a point here where puppet man
tells the kids to attack the Rangers
they don't get the chance but what were
they going to do this is almost taken as
a real threat what will you do and the
children attack you careful guy the only
saving grace of this episode is this
kids eyes
at least someone was having fun with
this and the number one worst Power
Rangers vo episode is a season to
remember I don't know what it is about
this show and Christmas episodes but
they're always terrible this was the
last view episode that aired on TV but
was supposed to be set earlier in the
season the order is fixed in the DVD
release tommy is an old man and telling
his grandchild a story about the Power
Rangers King mondo sends down prince
sprocket to put a spell on the team and
their friend Raymond that makes them
intolerant of different cultures from
their own in how they celebrate the
December holidays we'll get this out of
the way first everything with the
elderly versions of Tommy and cat is so
stupid
in so many ways what do you think young
fella you ready for Christmas
hold on youngster hold on getting late
you heard your grandmother it was bad
enough that they forced Tommy and cat
together and exploited Tommy's pink
Power Ranger fetish but flashing forward
in time and seeing that they end up
together and their grandkid is also a
Power Ranger was just too much even for
a Power Rangers Christmas episode we see
Jordan and alpha exchanged gifts as well
that this is sounding more and more like
another infamous direct-to-video
Christmas special you'd be right this
was supposed to be a home video
exclusive but that project was cancelled
so it ended up airing on TV there is
only one way to stop the spread of this
evil each Ranger of us find within his
heart the kindness and understanding
that is the key to every human soul next
thing you're going to tell me is the
spell is broken by a little girl singing
when I get mad my mommy sings me a song
you want to hear No
[Music]
I should have known better there you go
the worst of the Oh next we cover the
best and I'm excited to count down some
of my favorite episode it'll be a golden
good time I want to hear what you guys
think what is your least favorite
episode of Power Rangers Zeo what do you
want me to cover next to the show leave
a comment and let me know for more
content like my Mighty Morphin alien
Rangers review subscribe to my personal
channel youtube.com slash awesome
walther like when you Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome walter b and
follow along on twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future and now Rob you're mine
it's morphin time
[Music]
you